[Music]
when we started to go after Greg's dream
of being a professional longboard life
changed a lot you're out with your
father you're just out there having fun
like nothing really beats that like
chasing after the same dream I think
that's the best part about it for sure
[Music]
this is Mike Papp röszke he's my father
he does downhill skateboarding along
with Street luge
this is Greg Petrovski he's from Golden
Colorado
he's a downhill skateboarding downhill
longboarding is basically going down the
hill as fast as you can
Street luge is very similar to long
boarding except you lay down Greg still
is the youngest to have competed at the
Pikes Peak downhill race here in
Colorado Springs the fastest I've gone
today is 70 miles an hour but that's
that's about it
2011 my ex and I were going through a
divorce it was a big adjustment for
Gregg he was lashing out physically and
having problems in school I needed to
try to motivate him and get him on the
right track they told him if you get
your stuff together in school we can go
after any dream we want to I decided I
want to pursue longboarding because it
put me in the zone and make me forget
about all the negative things that were
happening in my life at the time so I
bought him a leather suit for Christmas
that year and and our first year on the
scene we traveled to Canada
New York Washington California we were
at the Ohio gravity games we rode the
free bus to within 5 miles of the event
and then we loved all of our luggage
down there it started raining on us we
had a two-man tent that's all we had and
as we were cuddle up in that tent with
all our gear and everything Gregory said
to me he goes dad he never told me the
dream was gonna be easy and it it was at
that point I knew this kid's got it he
understands like he gets it just being
able to be at the very lowest with my
father and the very highest we know that
we can tough out anything together and
that we can we can make it
I've seen great grow a lot since we
started skateboarding a lot of people
look at something and think oh I can't
can't do that Greg looks at it and says
how am I gonna do
[Music]
[Music]
yo hey yo Yama
ing yeah this is Eugene Lee and this is
his son you Ling you together they
create incredible sculptures out of
scrap metal
whatever solutions with another early
eating entities if we have suze because
India whose idea here also i feel ya do
I
this father-son duo got their start
making models of transformers may be
ethical binging and hassles or she is
open innovation that can adjust latency
today and so in she tells her that way
she had she said a lot of years right
Deegan ones who vote on yo-yo copaiba OT
go most important up you know that
mirror and you know they were in the
data you got a you about also meet the
father and son went on to expand the
business beyond just transformers and
began building their own designs
channels a woman's in consideration and
a true can go to heaven new earth army
berlin generously go the axillary users
in the south so on butter hand over Sara
Lee sujin valve to her selecting the
talent world missile
[Music]
hezonia girls I see a total of half and
they puzzle the other girls and I can't
even like anybody we can also take oppa
me ma and then go to what she window and
come let's just show more but I gotta
come home and your works having power
over the holiday you can catch it back
so yeah what's great about the
underlying layer then chokehold on a
single over code can be a server and
Ravana has no criminal record
the fear of a problem caboodle
[Music]
modify situation over a hilly lan kwai
condo means re-imposed
Lombardini head
again save Oregon carro está la nuit
Renta me Baba who knows Mario nació en
la Carrera Healy Ali Laurey su hijo en
si en dos ' blow Bryant Ernest Angley
[Music]
en el angel de sentido say verano la
carrera garen kueh grass allah allah
allah muhammad o my o GN at TI kappa ddr
Tobey on dopamine so ago an Arab Alesia
Desiree Vancouver dimensional a pity no
snow so nagakura
yo mind is si o my god o Muhammad don't
miss a
whip up with the
yeah currently messantia in a video
no basically given on learning Razia
zero zero
just one time I seen our Oh No Bhutan
local dango paciencia and the alumni a
mango
Miguel Rivera Volvo low key select a sin
no more Ferguson PD no la cosa Bella
yoga see para brain Delacour el al
cabron Darrell are carro
[Music]
siempre mine a given area McGonagall per
kilometer
okay Louie Sierra say ma fuluo Kuala
kosis a relation poke Romani Cena DNA KB
galiyev a lag cosas como se Coulomb
model DSS applet are my golden boy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
these little custard tarts these eggy
sugary treats are everywhere in Portugal
here here and here
some say the prestige the bilang is the
original post age Donata or a custard
tart in this little factory through this
kitchen there's a recipe that has been
kept top secret for almost 200 years
like this one guys you can get in here
I'm sorry ok I'm Miguel Tyrrhenian I'm
part of the management of the stage plan
this special recipe you will only find
here at this shop we sell an average of
about 20,000 tarts a day in the summer
maybe around 40,000 cakes a lot of kicks
per stage doubling as they call them
here are simple tarts really egg yolk
milk some flour sugar but it's how they
make them in complete secrecy
that makes these tarts a national
treasure we have six people knowing the
recipe in the family my father my cousin
and myself Nico Farina
the three chefs says Vitor Dominguez le
zero Ramiro and careless Matisse the
recipe is so secret all the Baker's
signed non-disclosure agreements to keep
the timeless tarts a true mystery which
taste of life is one of the earliest
recipes at least here in Lisbon we know
that the recipe was invented in the
monastery of Geronimo's in the early
19th century this one once they have the
recipe the chef's now sworn to secrecy
are giving keys to this door they work
inside the factory in a separate room
that we call the of Sina this video in
Portuguese like the secret shop or
secret room they have to work in a
separate room because the process
can only be seen by them so today we
haven't found anyone that explained the
recipe as it is if it happens well we
probably would have to lock him up in
the basement and throw away the key
no just kidding okay secret keeper
what's the best way to eat one of these
custard tarts usually I like it simple
but that's just me most people like with
a little bit of cinnamon on top this is
the hard part of the job I mean it's
just super hard I don't know how you do
it
[Music]
[Music]
if people could understand that this is
the kin to the scariest thing you've
ever done then they'll start to
understand why we're so addicted to it
when I put the goggles on first thing
I'm doing is trying to calm down
it totally puts you inside the drone you
just forget where you are
[Music]
I'm Conrad Miller also known as ferrati
and I'm a drone racer I started in
September 2014 and that was like the
ground floor
[Applause]
of all the activities I've partaken in
motorcycles and flying drones are on the
same level in terms of intensity it's
cool when you have a hobby and you can
do it and you love it but when you can
share it with your kids I mean that's
just you know that's just like what it's
all about I think ok so props are good
flying and racing with sorrell has just
been a pure joy he's a good kid he's a
talented kid and I think it comes easy
to set any kid like that because they
don't feel the pressure that adult to do
good landing
come on in hat this is harder than
anything else I've done and it's because
when you're when your nerves go your
fine motor still go kids don't care
there's having fun and they just learn
much faster and of course LA is at the
Hawthorne mall which is abandoned it's
been abandoned since the 80s I believe
and it looks like a place where you
would go if there was a zombie
apocalypse
[Music]
when I go into Grace's feel like I put a
lot of pressure on myself to win you
know I want all of my practice and all
of my time flying to show for something
I was flying by and I wasn't nervous but
I was just a little too high and crashed
[Music]
everybody is just working really hard to
be the best at it and it's just gonna
get tougher and tougher I take that 180
good ok did flying with Cyril now it
kind of gives me an opportunity to look
at it from a different perspective
because I can coach him ready mm-hmm
[Music]
he's aware enough to know that he gets
to do these things that most kids don't
get to do he's flying a drone which is
this groundbreaking thing we hit each
other
you hit me what you talking about we hit
each other you know as parents we don't
always feel like we do enough I brought
him in a drone racing and he knows he's
lucky and he knows he's fortunate yeah
kiddo you're going pretty quick and you
know he's just he's grateful for
everything that he gets
you
[Music]